I have to ask you something
two years ago you you came out you
revealed you were gay and you wrestled
with Andy I told you not to tell them
okay and that all day did you wrestle
with the decision to to announce this
you're in the public eye you were known
for it was it something you wrestled
with it all or those times completely
changed you know I I'm promoting a book
now so obviously I'm talking about it
but what I was genuinely afraid of his
eye I didn't want it to be my identity
you know when I needed to talk about it
I wanted to be able to talk about it and
I didn't want to why when I was watching
common in the 80s the only comedians
that were gay that talked about it did
these very formulaic acts and I would
watch stuff like this would be like when
I was younger everybody else played with
bar GI Joes i played with barbie dolls
though i was like good doesn't really
know that comic oh hello I go who's this
hello by the way except those two you
don't see him real-life anyone go hello
you know yes you do so so you thought I
want to I want to sort of I want to come
out and I want to humanize you know I
don't want it to be a caricature if I
talk about yeah I could just you know it
could be honest about who I was onstage
but also I didn't want to become a
character myself what you did and
everything's fine you know things great
right
you